[Music]
the fda recently approved pfizer's coven
19 vaccine which is freaking great news
now a lot of people felt skeptical
because the emergency rollout didn't
give enough time to thoroughly vet it
well now they have and you can relax
knowing that there is no poison
in the vaccine
isn't that right james it sure is amber
no poison in fact we have a song for all
those who may still be on the fence
about getting vaccinated
[Applause]
fights are vaccine in full effect are
you ready james i'm ready you ready
amber yeah i'm ready america are you
ricky
girl i must warn you
i sense that you're causing lots
situation is serious
let's cure it with two shots in the arm
it's all so ridiculous
conspiracy to receive from the stark
it's all so deadly
they believe it cause they aren't very
smart
check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
now some of them did there is no poison
[Applause]
fda approved
[Music]
if i were you i take precaution
before i get my news from facebook
information is out there
from qualified medical professionals
take a look
[Music]
they're so smart they have medical
expertise you think you know better
[ __ ] please don't be excluded for
thinking something stupid
you'll be dying all alone secluded
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for your politics you're picking out a
casket cause you wouldn't mask it see
what i'm saying huh suck in the house i
know your life's hard
how do you know no vaccination
[Applause]
card into their heads
miss information now some of them did
there is no poison
[Applause]
fda approved this time there is no
poison
[Applause]
[Music]
you